Jane Rosenthal robert de niro cofounders
of the Tribeca Film Festival it's a
pleasure to be here with you talking
about this festival that has meant so
much to independent film but also to New
York
how does it feel this is the 17th
festival as you all do all of this press
which I know you love doing and so much
fun to talk to all of us over and over
about the same thing when you think
about the fact that it was just over 16
years ago that you founded this what
does that make you feel no it feels
great I mean I we had no idea would last
this long or be as successful if you
want to call it that or popular so we're
very happy about that
I actually the first festival was four
days and I only thought we were doing it
once until Bob called me on the way home
and asked me why something didn't happen
and he said well next year just like
what next year we'll be doing this again
but anyway it's it's a real honor and
the creatives that come to the festival
it's and the audiences are pretty
spectacular when you look back at 16
festivals leading up to this year
are there some moments and some
premieres that really stand out and make
you proud and make you think this is
what this was all about the fifth year
the festival we had United 95 that Paul
Greengrass directed and it was we'd had
all the family members from that flight
had come and it was they had never felt
the outpouring of support that the rest
that New York City and and even the
Pentagon had found and it was just it
was just it was extremely emotional they
[Music]
they were kept grabbing you know all of
us
it was and I remember thinking do we
have a red carpet and I was like yes of
course you'd have a red carpet they were
there too
to celebrate but you know we had to have
grief counselors around afterwards it
was it was it was it was really intense
well there was another for me there was
another moment when the grand Rebbe in
Brooklyn had Williams Brooklyn had
blessed this Israeli film that we had
and I got up to introduce the film and
they were all sitting with hats on
[Music]
President Sirleaf okay Liberia oh yeah
yeah yeah that was a special time all of
a sudden we're in a theater and you know
in the village and they're like they say
Oh President of Liberia is that how this
happens you you all it sounds like you
occasionally get surprised while the
festival is going on that something
becomes an event or that attention has
brought to a certain film yes it's the
one thing about Tribeca is you never
know what to expect there was one year
to we had this film about this kid from
the favelas that became a ballet dancer
and just dancing and one of the New York
companies and he hadn't seen the film
and at the end as the credits were you
know credits going crazier going and the
lights came up all of a suddent this kid
just dances from the back of the room
and then leaps I mean it was just this
the most joyous spectacular
because he hadn't seen it and you know
very there he was in front of this
audience but it was watching him dance
in front of this theater was really
amazing in 16 years film has changed so
much this festival has reflected that in
very interesting ways
now you highlight virtual reality video
games even online filmmaking television
what are you most excited about I would
I would ask you first what what are you
most excited about about where film has
come and where it's headed
I don't know if I'm excited I mean it's
just the new forms that are emerging and
I'm curious to see where it goes I just
I don't know I mean I mean virtual
reality is something that I'm excited
but I don't know I don't see it working
quite yet except in certain things in
the script like if you see it like for
medical reasons and stuff like that but
for personal reasons I mean that it's
great for medical or if you want to show
something and you can't be there you can
actually get the experience of but
that's something but I I don't know I I
don't know I don't know I'm curious to
see where it goes
all right they are I'm I'm thinking of
where that's people are some people are
worried that it'll take over in some
ways and I could see that by the a are
being perfection because it's not the
human will make us will make us it will
remind us that we've made a mistake and
how far do you carry that where then
what do you pay for that mistake by by
this whatever this being is that's
that's what supposedly you've created to
help you and aid you and something that
you can't do by yourself but now they
were superior in certain ways that made
you have to worry about their to use a
word that I don't like to use a special
excuse by the administration loyalty
we have two narratives about that at the
festival one is called Jonathan and I
know there is jarana misses a film that
really looks at the AR AI components of
what happens when that is in your life
you know more profound way I just want
to know what's your hope I mean this
this this thing you created you thought
was gonna be one year has now become
such a global event what is your hope
for the legacy of the Tribeca Film
Festival in the future that it becomes a
New York institution that it's that
great filmmakers and storytellers come
out of it and you get to entertain some
people yeah I mean that's it that it
would be a a tradition in New York
that's that will last that'll be part of
the fabric of New York City that'd be
that'd be great